their policies we'll find out further on
the 31st of October when he sets out the
full picture both the spending and the
tax side of things so I think she's gone
a long way to stabilize matters you've
seen that in the markets the markets are
now much much calmer than they were and
I think once we get through the 31st of
October I think we'll be much camera
Waters then okay let's bring in Steven
Malhotra for the labor party Shadow
business Minister uh SEMA what do you
think kirstan will want to hear from the
Prime Minister today
I think what we will want to hear I
think what the country will want to hear
is uh firstly an apology in Parliament
from the Prime Minister I think there's
no points just apologizing in a media
interview or
um or doing it from under a hiding under
a table or not hiding under a table I
think people are really really worried
about what's coming and I think there's
a worry uh for me that the government is
now going to get complacent by saying
that they've slightly stabilized the
markets for now I mean what situation
are we in if we're watching guilt yield
every day and seeing that that is
somehow a new normal behavior
I want to make sure I want to hear from
the Prime Minister on whether she had
really realized the impact that her
decisions have had because this is a
crisis made in Downing Street we know
that inflations are borrowings up
mortgage rates up and I've had a
constituent contact me with um with with
their new mortgage rate which is 6.1
percent
I want to hear her apologize in
Parliament to him and to others across
the country that so many families across
the country who are now paying a Tory
premium of hundreds of pounds extra on
their mortgage bills every day that
hasn't stopped this is the reason why I
think the Prime Minister has to
acknowledge the damage has been done and
she may have changed her Chancellor to
have the fourth now toy Chancellor in
four months but we haven't seen the
stability in the financial stability and
economic stability that our country
desperately needs John Stevenson for the
conservatives that is a fair point is it
isn't it your right to say the markets
have stabilized but the fact is that
they they only wobbled because of the
policies that she tried to implement
well they have stabilized now but we've
also got to accept there is an
international scene going on here as
well interest rates are rising in the
United Kingdom but they're Rising across
the world in America and Europe but
there was a massive spike in all of the
metrics we know that after the mini
budget but as we have now got stable
we've got now got stability you've seen
interest rates start to drop back to
more normal
um values we've also seen across the
world inflation writing we've seen
interest rates Rising so we're not
unique in that sense what I think we've
now got a stability from the new
Chancellor we'll have a pro um his
program set out in the 31st of October
which will set out exactly where we are
in tax and spend and I think you'll see
far greater stability in the markets
which then allows us to concentrate on
growing the economy because one thing
the Prime Minister did get absolutely
right when she set out our vision
originally was we have to grow the
economy and it's only through growing
the economy that will improve people's
lives we will see leveling up happen
we'll see a rebalancing in the economy
and we will see the finances of the
country improve which then allow you to
spend money on public services so we've
got to get the fundamentals right the
vision that the Prime Minister
originally set out was absolutely
correct unfortunately how they went
about it initially was wrong and I think
she's fully accepted that but where we
are now is in a much much better place
and I think you'll see improvements in
the course of the next few months Simi
Malhotra said that she would like to see
an apology do you think get an apology
from the Prime Minister well I think the
prime minister's already set out that in
her interview earlier in the week I
think we need to move on from that we
have a we've now got the new Chancellor
in place I think we've got the policies
we've got to look forward to the 31st of
October we've got to set out the agenda
for the future I think next year you'll
start to see inflation fall I think
you'll start to see gas prices hopefully
drop as well and I think you'll start to
see an improved economic position the
chancellor is absolutely right we've got
to be fiscally conservative to make sure
that we do balance the boots so that the
markets are comfortable with what we are
doing but I actually think that is
precisely what is happening
let's just bring you back in I mean as
John John was saying things are a lot
more stable than they were even as
recently as Monday
let's look at what's coming now this is
not over we have now seen the Prime
Minister and the chancellor talking
about public sector Cuts Public Services
cut that could end up being another
austerity season two and we're still
recovering from season one and let's not
forget the chancellor was also in
government and uh part of this austerity
season one I do not understand how the
government have
um are are now saying that working
people pensioners and now our Public
Services
are going to be the ones that need to
pay for the mistakes that the government
has made these were not things being
talked about three or four weeks ago the
damage has been done and the
consequences now are going to be felt by
the British people and if the
conservatives think that cutting doctors
and nurses and our police are going to
be a way out of this Tory created mess a
mess made in Downing Street by the Prime
Minister and her chancellors then I
think they've got another thing coming
and the British people are going to want
to hear much better than this from the
Prime Minister we're joined Now by
Christine Jardin from the liberal
Democrats I understand that liberal
Democrats are possibly reaping the
benefits of this trust's lack of
popularity you've seen quite a lot more
donors and some contentious seats oh yes
but sadly I do like to think of it as
ripping the benefits I think what we're
seeing is a reflection of people's
dissatisfaction with
um Liz Trice and so government because
experience says if that's what we do I'm
so sorry Christine
about
service failures that the NHS should
have known about first and did not
carrying out the investigation
I've kept that in mind as much as but
not more than what has actually happened
in East Kent
what has happened in this Kent is
deplorable and harrowing we have
numerous instances of care that was not
given to the right standards
consistently failed to meet standards
with deaths and significant harm in
schools of families
it had 202 families that came forward in
97 deaths injuries or other harm could
have been different if care had been
given to the standards accepted
nationally
in 45 of the 65 stillborn and
newborn babies who died
they could have had a different outcome
had care been given to the standards
accepted accepted nationally
as well as that we found that there had
been frequent instances where
significant harm was caused to people's
well-being
by the unkind and callous way on
occasions that they were treated and
some have been deeply affected by that
many have been deeply affected by that
we haven't found that there's been a
single clinical cause of the failure
what we've found is four underlying
themes that led directly to these
problems
the first is Extreme failures of
teamworking as you know maternity care
has to be delivered by groups of
professionals working together from
different
grounds from different professions they
have to work together effectively they
did not and there are various reasons
for that including lack of trust and
lack of respect but there is also
inescapably the fact that professionals
can sometimes
get the impression that they're working
to different goals
it might be to reduce the amount of
intervention or it might be to not
reduce the amount of intervention a team
that works to different goals in my view
is not a team
secondly failures of professionalism of
compassion and of kindness people were
dealt with
rudely
arrogantly and with hostility and you'll
find numerous examples
in the report women were not listened to
they reported
a range of things that should have been
listened to for example that they were
in labor for example that their
membranes had ruptured for example that
the baby's movements had altered and
they were disregarded and that led
directly to instances of harm
the same failures of compassion and
listening happened after devastating
outcomes such as the death of a baby
people were treated
with dismissiveness and denial
not only does that cause people deep
distress it also prevents learning so
that the same set of mistakes kept
happening over again because people were
not properly looking and learning on at
least eight separate occasions over a
10-year period the trust board was
presented with what should have been
inescapable signals that there were
serious problems in the maternity unit
they could have acknowledged that they
could have investigated they could have
put it right that started in 2010 the
first instance was in 2010.
but they didn't in every single case
they found a way to deny that there were
problems to disregard to say that on the
whole Services were okay or at least
good enough and they were wrong to do
that as a result of that the pattern of
behavior and of harm continued unaltered
through the entire period of the
investigation till the end of 2020.
it need not have happened like not
what do we do in previous investigations
including my own
we have sought to set out detailed
operational recommendations to change
this do that don't do that
I think the time has passed to do that
we cannot pretend that this works any
longer all that happens is we have
another instance of the same problem
cropping up again
as a result of that I've not sought to
set out detailed operational
recommendations I have identified four
major underlying areas that need to be
acted on and they need other people I
can't do it as an independent
investigation but they need the
leadership of the Health Service they
need ministers they need NHS England to
act on these four areas otherwise I very
much fear that we will all be back
probably not me but you all will be back
somewhere else in a year or Tuesday
the four areas
firstly we have to find a way to detect
dysfunctional units as they're beginning
to slide not after and saying that
things have gone wrong with Services we
should never position we have to have a
mechanism I'm proposing a way to do that
through something I would call a
maternity signaling system which takes
information we largely have and which
shows shows women it shows clinicians it
shows trusts and it shows NHS England
where people stand on their outcomes and
on their safety and which direction
they're trending and whether the
variations from month to month are
random or whether they're systematic and
therefore there is a need to look if
we'd had a system like that in 2010 I
believe that the problems would have
been inescapable then it's beyond time
that we had one and I think we must work
on that
um
secondly I think we have to address the
problems of inappropriate and uncaring
behavior that cropped up time and again
in East Kent we heard so many accounts
of it
I understand of course the NH NHS staff
are operating under strain at the moment
I absolutely appreciate that but that is
not an excuse for uncaring rude or
aggressive behavior which is what we
found and we do not believe that this is
entirely restricted to East Kent that
would be a dangerous assumption
third I think we must have a coherent
basis for team working in maternity
eternity is
like all clinical Specialties dependent
on
multi-professional groups working
together in a coherent team it's
probably more dependent on that than
some other Specialties and yet the
challenges appear to be greater in
maternity I can't escape the fact that
some of that is about people picking up
mixed messages about what their
objectives are are they there to reduce
the amount of intervention or are they
there to continue with the same amount
of intervention or to do more
intervention you can't have a team that
functions with different objectives
and finally I think we have to address
the problem of trusts responding to
legitimate inquiries and questions with
deflection and denial they do this in
the name of reputation management It's a
cruel practice that ends up with
families such as the ones that I've just
been talking to being denied the truth
that's a terrible thing to do to
somebody on the name of protecting your
reputation
I think that the current incentives for
trusts clearly don't dissuade them from
doing it because it is the standard
response
and there has to be a better mechanism
to make sure that they don't do that I
think that I would and I do recommend a
statutory provision for this it's been
called the Hillsborough law in the past
but it would place if enacted it would
place a statutory Duty a legal Duty on
public bodies to be truthful and not to
conceal problems when they had a result
the findings of the investigation are
Stark and the conclusions are shocking
and uncomfortable
I thank everybody who has helped us that
includes the staff of the trust but most
of all the families who gave up their
time and a lot of themselves to help us
understand what had happened we owe it
to all of them to listen to take very
seriously what has happened and to
address the areas that have been set out
to make sure
for the sake of services in East Kent
and wider that these problems are
eradicated
thank you I'm happy to take questions
that you might have at the
moments you can keep going
well that was Dr Bill Kirk up there
um in his own words described as Stark
and shocking this report that he's
carried out into treatment of women and
babies at East Kent hospitals University
NHS trust he said their treatment was
deplorable and harrowing that 45 of 65
babies who died stillborn could have had
a different outcome he said that the
four underlying failures were failures
of teamwork failures of professionalism
failures of listening to women treating
women who were going through a really
difficult time with rudeness hostility
and a lack of compassion and said that
the trust knew about these problems 10
years ago the board were told eight
times in ten years he said they didn't
act and they were wrong and this pattern
of behavior and calm and Calamity
happened all the way to the end of 2020
and he has suggested a number of things
including making it a statutory
requirement that bodies such as this
have to respond truthfully he said that
the trust
deflected and denied problems when
families brought it to them and that
this has to stop that it made the
situation worse for families the same
mistakes happened again and again a
really damning report into what has
happened over a 10-year period at East
Kent Hospital University NHS trust I'm
sure we'll have a lot more on that
throughout the day here on Sky News but
for now we're just about to reach the
point on a Wednesday when we have Prime
Ministers questions and it's been a
terrifically difficult week for the
Prime Minister once again a political
editor Beth Rigby is here with me in the
studio Beth she left number 10 just from
20 minutes ago heading to the commons
um what is going on this is another
tough week for her as it is but we're
also now seeing this potential vote on
fracking coming up I mean
I think it's fair to say that this is
still a government very much in chaos
and as I understand it the Prime
Minister has also recently suspended one
of her own team in number 10 admit
allegations of briefing against other
MPS so there's another crisis emerging
for her within her own team I mean
letters to Graham Brady yes and in terms
of uh prime minister's questions uh
number one she has to try and put in a
really great performance because MPS
want to see how she can stand up against
kirstama after all of these u-turns but
even despite that as you said there is
now a big battle over a fracking motion
that labor are putting onto the floor
today and there is talk about gray and
Brady indicating to the Prime Minister
that he is set in a higher threshold for
a potential confidence vote now she
should be protected from a confidence
vote for a year as a new prime minister
under the traditional rules you have to
have 15 percent of the Parliamentary
party that's 54 MPS right into the chair
of the back bench committee to say that
he wants a confidence
meetings later today
thank you Mr Speaker when the penny
dropped for the Prime Minister on Monday
and she realized that her budget was
responsible for crashing the economy she
should have come to this house to
explain herself and to apologize to the
millions of people who will now be
paying hundreds of pounds extra a month
on their mortgages because of her
mistakes but now she's here can she tell
us given the absolute chaos her
government has created while the
chancellor lost his job but she kept
hers
foreign
Mr Speaker I have been very clear that I
am
[Applause]
made mistakes but the right thing to do
in those circumstances is to make
changes which I've made and to get on
with the job and deliver for the British
people and Mr Speaker we've delivered
the energy price guarantee we've helped
people this winter and I will continue
to do that
Lawrence Robertson
thank you Mr Speaker does the Prime
Minister agree with me that local people
and local councils are best placed to
decide how many houses they need and
where those houses should go yeah and if
she does Will she end the top-down
approach to housing targets and reduce
or preferably remove the powers of the
planning inspector yeah prime minister
well my honorable friend is absolutely
right we will abolish the top-down
housing targets we want foreign
decisions about homes about
infrastructure driven by local people
not driven by Whitehall and that's why
we're setting up new locally driven
investment zones
[Applause]
a book is being written about the prime
minister's time in office
apparently it's going to be out by
Christmas is that the release date or
the title
laughs
well Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
I have been in office for just under two
months and I have delivered the energy
price guarantee
paying six thousand pound bills this
winter I've reversed the National
Insurance increase and I've also taken
steps and we will be taking steps to
crack down on the militant unions now
what what Mrs Baker I think Mr Speaker
that is more of a record of action than
the honorable gentleman in his two and a
half years in the job
[Applause]
Mr Speaker last week the Prime Minister
ignored every question put to her
instead she repeatedly criticized
Labor's plan for a six-month freeze on
energy bills this week the chancellor
made it her policy
be held to account when she's not in
charge
[Applause]
oh Mr Speaker our policy is to protect
the most vulnerable for two years
I had to take the decision because of
the economic situation to adjust our
policies
somebody who's prepared to front up I'm
prepared to take the tough decisions
unlike The Honorable gentleman who
hasn't done anything on businesses he's
done nothing to say he'll protect people
after one year he's got no plan
[Applause]
Mr Speaker last week the Prime Minister
stood there and promised absolutely no
spending reductions they all cheered
this week the chancellor announced a new
wave of cards what's the point of a
prime minister whose promises don't even
last a week
[Applause]
yeah and it will go up the year after
but of course we need to get value for
taxpayers money the labor party has
pledged hundreds of billions of spending
pledges none of which they've retracted
The Honorable gentleman needs to reflect
the economic reality in his policy
yeah
Mr Speaker those spending cuts are on
the table for one reason and one reason
only because they crashed the economy
[Applause]
working working people working people
are going to have to pay 500 quid more a
month on their mortgages and what's the
prime minister's response
to say she's sorry
what does she think people will think
and say that's all right I don't mind
Financial ruin at least she apologized
prime minister
I do think there has to be some
reflection of economic reality from the
party
[Applause]
interest rates are rising across the
world and the economic conditions have
worsened and we are being honest we're
leveling with the public unlike The
Honorable gentleman who simply won't do
it and what is the honorable gentleman
doing about the fact that workers train
workers are again going on strike the
fact is he refuses to condemn the
workers we are bringing forward policies
Mr Speaker we are bringing forward
policies that are going to make sure our
Railways are protected people going to
work are protected he backs the strikers
we back the Strivers
Mr Speaker she's asking me questions
because we're a government in Waiting
there's no exactly there's no getting
away from this millions of people are
facing horrendous mortgage repayments
and she's admitted it's her fault she
shouldn't have conducted an economic
experiment on the British public but
it's not just her they put her there
they're keeping her there why on Earth
would anyone trust the tourists with the
economy ever again
foreign
Mr Speaker he's not actually objecting
to a single economic policy
at Monday
he's refusing to condemn the strikers
where on the side of working people
we're going to legislate to make sure we
keep our Railways open The Honorable
gentleman refuses to do anything
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the only mandate she's ever
had is from Members opposite yeah it was
a mandate built on fantasy economics and
it ended in disaster the country's got
nothing to show for it except the
destruction of the economy and the
implosion of the Tory party I've got the
list here 45p tax cut gone corporation
tax cut gone 20p tax cut gone two-year
energy freeze gone tax-free shopping
gone economic credibility God
and her supposed best friend the formula
Chancellor he's gone as well they're all
gone so why is she still here
oh Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I am a fighter and not a
quitter
they have acted in the National interest
to make sure that we have economic
stability order
I'm good to hear the Prime Minister I
suggest that all members need to hear
the answer prime minister
yeah yeah
Mr Speaker
I am a fighter
delivered on
on price guarantee we have we delivered
on the energy price guarantee we've
delivered on National Insurance we are
going to deliver to stop the militant
trade unions disrupting our Railways The
Honorable gentleman has no idea he has
no plan and he has no alternative
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
's rugby league team on their recent
promotion to Super League bringing
Millions to the local economy and
furthermore would she also guarantee
there are excellent women's Euros team
including Ella tune from my constituency
tilsley will receive the number 10
reception that they so deserve
foreign
I joined I joined my honorable friend in
congratulating the Lee centurions on
their return to the Super League I had
the huge privilege of meeting the
lionesses last week a fantastic team who
won a major tournament for us we will
host the Downing Street reception as
soon as their training program makes
them available
I look forward to rugby league invite as
well let's not come for the leader of
the SMP in Black
thank you Mr Speaker after 10 u-turns in
two weeks
we're left with a prime minister in
office but not in power and families are
paying through the teeth
for her mistakes her latest broken
promise has put pensioners in the front
line of Tory Cuts so can the Prime
Minister perhaps turned her Chancellor
right now get permission to make another
U-turn and commit to raising the state
pension at the rate of inflation
prime minister I honestly don't know
what the honorable gentleman is talking
about because way
we have been clear in our Manifesto that
we will maintain the triple lock and I
am completely committed to it so is the
chancellor
[Applause]
approval ratings are collapsing with an
answer like that the worst calling
result for any prime minister in history
she's just thrown 12 million pensioners
under the Tony boss
[Applause]
I also want to hear Mr Blackford
Mr Speaker it's not just pensioners
feeling the pain in the last week alone
inflation has risen to a 40-year high
mortgage rates are at the highest level
since the financial crash and people's
energy bills are about to rise to more
than five thousand pounds can the Prime
Minister answer one simple question why
does she expect everyone else to pay the
price for her failure prime minister
I don't think the honorable gentleman
can take yes for an answer
be clear we are protecting the triple
and if the if the honorable gentleman is
concerned about the economy why does he
continue to advocate for separatism
[Applause]
into chaos
thank you very much
over the last couple of years thousands
of homes have been proposed or built in
Birmingham Northfield constituency which
puts a huge strain on GP and dangerous
appointments what's my right on my
friend the Prime Minister agree with me
but more needs to be done in the
planning process to make sure that when
we have large-scale development we have
more capacity in those vital Services
prime minister my honorable friend is
absolutely right when we build new
houses we need to make sure there are GP
surgeries
skulls infrastructure and that's why
we're introducing a new infrastructure
Levy to make sure more of the money from
developers goes on supporting local
communities
[Applause]
Ed Mr Speaker millions of family carers
have been forced to cut back on food and
Heating
one told carers UK my son is incontinent
if we don't wash him in warm water
several times a day this will cause him
to physically decline
so how do we pay for the gas to heat the
water if we are currently at Max budget
for all people and carers are struggling
enough already in this cost of living
crisis Mr Speaker
so will the Prime Minister guarantee
that support for the vulnerable
including carers allowance Will Rise by
at least today's inflation rate of 10.1
percent
[Applause]
are struggling it is difficult at the
moment that's why we put it in place the
energy price guarantee to make sure the
typical household isn't paying more than
2 500 pounds it's why we've supplied an
extra 1200 pounds of support to the most
vulnerable and I can assure the right
honorable gentleman we will always
support the most vulnerable they will be
our priority
hey Jones
thank you Mr Speaker Bracken of Radnor
has a proud military footprint
not least the Cambrian Patrol exercise
which I visited last week it is
considered the Olympic gold medal in
infantry training attracting teams from
across the world to compete in a 60
kilometer March over two days in the
brecon beacons will the Prime Minister
join me in congratulating all those who
took part not least the team of Gurkha
soldiers from the Infantry battle School
in Brecken who took home a coveted gold
medal further cementing brecken's
special place in the UK Armed Forces
I joined my honorable friend in thanking
everybody of Brecken Barrett who
organizes the exercise Cambrian Patrol
each year it is a world-class training
exercise and I congratulate brecken's
Gurkha soldiers for their fantastic
achievement of a gold medal well done Dr
Philippa Whitford
thank you very much Mr Speaker it took
just five working days for the prime
minister to crash the pound damage
Pension funds and send people's mortgage
costs spirally her new Chancellor may
have reversed almost all of her policies
but the damage has been done and we now
face yet another round of Tory cuts and
austerity so I'd last like to ask the
Prime Minister and those sitting behind
her why is she still at the dispatch box
and when will voters get their say on
this disastrous government prime
minister
we are facing very very difficult
Economic Times I took
[Applause]
two in the interests of economic
stability and what is important is we
work together including with the SMP to
get through this winter and grow the
economy there
are prime minister is to be commended
for securing the passage of the Northern
Ireland protocol built through this
house without Amendment before the
summer recess can she confirm that it's
the government's intention that the bill
should remain unamended and in
particular that the European court of
justice should have no jurisdiction in
any part of the United Kingdom prime
minister I am completely committed to
the Northern Ireland protocol bill it
deals with the very specific issues we
face in Northern Ireland the free-frow
of trade and also making sure that the
people of Northern Ireland are able to
benefit from being part of the United
Kingdom and I can tell my honorable
friend that any negotiations will
reflect the same position that is in the
protocol bill they beg Hillier yeah yeah
Mr Speaker we understand that this
afternoon's vote on fracking is deemed a
confidence vote in the Prime Minister
can she give us any reason why her own
back Ventures or anyone in this country
can have confidence in her after her
policies have caused chaos in the
markets and wrecked the economy
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we do face very difficult
Economic Times I have been honest about
the mistakes I have made but what I
don't apologize for is the fact that we
have helped households through this
winter through the energy price
guarantee the fact that we've reversed
the National Insurance Rise And the fact
we are taking action to get our Railways
running rather than being disrupted by
the militant trade unions she supports
Mr Speaker there's been a number of low
points recently including
the Republic of Ireland's football team
singing pro-ira songs in the changing
room we should never forget the
sacrifice of those who paid the price to
maintain the Peace during the troubles
closer to home recent events meant that
spending is going to be more constrained
than originally thought may I encourage
the prime minister to ensure that we
retain compassion in politics in these
decisions including maintaining the link
between
benefits and inflation will she do that
remember this stuff we are we are
compassionate conservatives we will
always
[Applause]
work with the energy price guarantee we
are going to make sure the most
vulnerable are protected into year two
and I'm sure the chancellor has heard
my honorable friends
representations on the contents of the
medium term physical plan Stuart Malcolm
McDonald thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
let the public at large have supported
the government in terms of the actions
it has taken to support Ukraine not
least because of of what's at stake
there but right now in order to maintain
that support as the public deals with
Rising prices inflation mortgage costs
and much else Ukraine fatigue is a real
and present danger and I'm afraid to say
to the Prime Minister she is now an
active driver against that public
support that has so unified many of us
that has sought unified the has so
unified many of us to do what needs to
be done
so in a time where
[Applause]
in a time where in a time where resolve
and support of Ukraine needs to be
stealed will she make sure that she
commits from the dispatch box that the
economic and Military and political
support won't be another casualty under
this prime minister
to make sure the military support we
give to Ukraine is equal to the military
support we gave this year we must make
sure Ukraine win they can win they will
win and they must win
um Mr Speaker I would like to thank the
Prime Minister for sticking by her words
and giving communities and filed the
final say on fracking but as always the
devil is in the detail can the Prime
Minister assure me that local consent
will be measured independently and
transparently and under no circumstances
will fracking companies be directly
engaged in assessing local consent and
if people unfiled say no that that view
and that decision will be respected and
acted upon by this government
[Music]
my honorable friend I know this is
something he cares deeply about I can
ensure him that we will consult on the
robust system of local consent give
clear advice on seismic limits and
safety before any fracking takes place
and the consultation will consider all
of the relevant people the regional
Mayors the local authorities and
parishes as well as the concerns of
those directly affected and my right
honorable friend the business secretary
will be saying more about this later
today
[Music]
yeah thank you Mr Speaker privatization
does not work it doesn't work for our
NHS we have another Amber Alert in the
NHS Blood Service a service that this
week's Chancellor sold when he was
Health secretary and it doesn't work for
our Postal Service with Royal Mail group
taking 758 million pounds in profit last
year yeah our Universal service
obligation is at risk workers pay
conditions and 10 000 jobs are at threat
will the Prime Minister continue to let
obscene amounts of profit be made while
services are cut and stamp prices rise
or will she launch an inquiry into the
gross mismanagement of Royal Mail and
minister
what we need is an efficient Postal
Service that delivers for people across
this country and that's what I'm focused
on not making ideological points
good Baker thank you
thank you speaker when I was in business
it was a real privilege to employ very
many talented bright young people
I always found that when you believed in
somebody when you gave them the
opportunity they went on to thrive in
their career that's why tomorrow in
North Norfolk I'll be launching my new
scheme the 100 apprenticeship challenge
to drive a hundred new apprenticeships
all over a rural constituency would the
Prime Minister please thank not just my
DWP office and Juliet Nix has been
fantastic the district councils the
county councils and an awful lot of
stakeholders that work for over six
months to deliver this fantastic scheme
to drive growth and jobs for young
people across my constituency
yeah well I do want to thank Julia and
her team for the fantastic job they're
doing and also you as the local member
of sorry my writable friend is a local
Member of Parliament apprenticeships are
a fantastic way for people to learn and
gain experience and I'm proud that we've
created 5.1 million apprenticeships
since 2010. Smith
Mr Speaker
the prime minister's chief of staff is
in hot water after lobbying on behalf of
a Libyan warlord a big tobacco
it turns out he's also lobbied for PPE
Giants Sante global Is it wise to have a
lobbyist at the center of doning Street
prime minister
[Applause]
Mr Speaker all appointments in Downing
Street are properly checked through the
propriety and ethics process and that is
the way that we do it in a completely
impartial way Andrew made Joel
thank you Mr Speaker when my right
honorable friend was foreign secretary I
know that she was acutely aware of the
importance of British soft power acting
in our national interest will she
confirm today the promise we both made
in 2010 when this government first came
into office that she will not balance
the books on the backs of the poorest
people in the world
[Music]
well can I pay tribute to my right
honorable friend for the Fantastic work
he did as International Development
secretary and I am proud that we have
rebalanced our International Development
budget to focus more on humanitarian Aid
and more on women and girls and no doubt
more details will be set out in due
course
[Music]
thank you Mr
space Tori prime minister was forced out
after a series of dodgy dealings and
failing to take responsibility for any
of it so what's this prime minister
getting the boot for her plan that
crashed the economy forcing fracking on
communities who don't want it or she did
the decent thing and go and call a
general election
[Applause]
I have taken responsibility and I have
made the right decision in the interests
of the country's economic stability
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker every single member
in this house will have constituents
waiting for treatment within the kobit
backlog
the health secretary's priorities are
absolutely right including her B for
tackling the backlogs can the Prime
Minister reassure me that the government
is committed to the series of elective
hubs that we've promised including at
the Royal Hampshire County Hospital in
my Winchester constituency prime
minister
well the my right horrible friend the
health secretary has set out her plans
to deliver on dealing with the covered
backlog and she will continue to work on
that and make sure we deal with what was
a massive you know a massive pandemic a
massive pandemic creating a backlog we
will deal with it
yeah
since the mini budget thousands of my
constituents have been in mental anguish
and despair I recognize that The
Honorable lady has faced a week of
mental anguish and despair herself
she has been had people angry with her
she's had people who have mocked her but
having had that experience what will she
now do to improve the health care the
mental health care for people in this
country so that the the the anguish that
they face in the coming months is
properly responded to and dealt with
I could say my rights would befriend the
health secretary has set out a very
clear plan of how we're going to deal
with the backlog created by covid how
we're going to make sure people get
timely GP appointments and how we're
going to improve on the services in our
hospitals including Mental Health
Services
thank you Mr Speaker the government is
facing tough choices but people living
with dementia face unlimited care costs
and that is not a choice can my right
honor a friend assure me that she is
committed to social care reform to end
that worry and relieve pressure on the
NHS
yes we are committed to social care
reform we do need to deal with those
issues
Breezy
thank you Mr Speaker it's always better
to see a prime minister at her desk
rather than underneath it
Atlas
why next week this house will be
discussing legislation that will abolish
vital protections on pension payouts it
will abolish
our right to watch the Olympics free of
charge and Airline consumer laws how is
any of the retained law bill in the
British interest prime minister
well Mr Speaker I think we have yet
another example of somebody who doesn't
want to support the British Public's
decision to leave the European Union
isn't it isn't it quite I'm sorry isn't
it quite incredible Mr Speaker that six
years after people voted to leave the
European Union there are people who
object to taking EU law off our statute
books now I'm a Democrat I respect what
Finnish people voted for I suggest yes I
suggest the right rockable lady does the
same
Legend Graham Mr Speaker 30 years ago
the Westminster foundation for democracy
was created out of the war in Bosnia so
that democracies could flourish in
Freedom and prosperity come with it
this evening in your rooms we celebrate
that anniversary by hearing directly
from our country representative in
Ukraine from the chair of the Taiwanese
Foreign Affairs committee and the leader
of the opposition in Uganda a good
example of the range of contacts that
this great cross-party body funded by
government is working with can I ask the
Prime Minister if she agrees that this
is a vital contribution by our
government and our people to democracy
around the world and will she encourage
members around the house to join us this
evening
prime minister well the Westminster
foundation for democracy does a
fantastic job and I think we know from
what has happened in Ukraine the
appalling War perpetrated by Vladimir
Putin just how precious democracy is and
how much we need to do to work with our
friends and allies to protect democracy
around the world and I do encourage
colleagues from all sides of the house
to attend the event tonight that no
complete members those questions I'll
let the house clear
well Laos is clearing at the end of
prime minister's questions
um lots to discuss let's bring in our
political editor Beth Rigby I mean
there's first of all Beth is there's the
the tune fro between her and kirstarma
but also quite crucially what appears to
be a Divergence of policy between her
and her Chancellor so it started off as
this the main story of this pmqs being
the exchanges between starmer and her
the the league of the opposition with
this kind of mix of mockery and contempt
for the Prime Minister who her part said
I am a fighter actually borrowing uh
Peter mandelson's line there but she was
really in fighting form there trying to
put in a good performance but the
bombshell in that chamber was her
response to a question on uplifting or
maintaining the pensions triple lot this
is when pensions rise in line with
inflation if that's the highest of three
uh just three areas where you might lift
it by but essentially it's like will you
lift uh pensions will you up rate them
with inflation now Jeremy Hunt clearly
said on Monday that he would not commit
to this policy he said I'm not making
any specific commitments on spending
until October the 31st he explicitly
ruled it out in an interview with me
where I explicitly asked he explicitly
ruled it out in the comments the Prime
Minister has stood up there and has
overruled her Chancellor she has said in
the comments that she it was a Manifesto
commitment it was a pledge she made when
she was trying to be leader and she has
said clearly there on the floor of the
commons I am committed to operating uh
with inflation pensions now there's a
couple of things going on there one
she's facing a back bench Rebellion on
this issue a number of MPS have already
got out come out publicly saying this
was a Manifesto commitment promise you
made when you're a leader you cannot
undo it so she knew she had a political
battle
but the issue is is that she brought
Jeremy hunting in order to study the
ship calm the markets he took control of
tax and spend decisions quite clearly on
Monday and the Prime Minister there at
the dispatch box has publicly overruled
him now I've got so many questions on
that does he agree with her if he
doesn't how will he react will this
unnerve the markets that the prime
minister is again making policy on the
hoof that she might have to you turn on
she's done another u-turn on a U-turn
and so the reason that this is
politically really interesting is that
she needs Jeremy Hunt
in order to have any credibility at all
of staying in number 10 and she has just
publicly overruled him in the Commons
and I'm very interested to see how
Jeremy Hunt and the treasury react to
that now maybe uh he was fine with that
but that was not what he said four
straight hours ago and hasn't the story
of this government in terms of the
market turmoil and the voter
dissatisfaction being about saying one
thing doing another saying one thing
doing another and the Prime Minister has
just done that again when Jeremy Hunt
said I'm making no specific tax and
spend commitments until the fiscal
statement on October the 31st she just
blew that up well indeed and that
contradicted something she'd said about
no more spending cuts last week but
again he absolutely ruled out three days
later on so if you are that's exactly
right Jade so if you're a conservative
MP you have a prime minister that says
the things that the dispatch box is
there any credibility at all in what she
says why is she undermining what was set
up in order to be
an attempt to stabilize things and I
think that there's a question for me
certainly like was that an agreed
decision James cleverley her foreign
secretary was on Sky news this morning
refusing to commit to that policy and
that's another element of this chain if
you're a prime minister and you're very
embattled as she clearly is you need
your cabinet to back you because if one
of them decides that they're going to
stand down that's when it could trigger
flood of resignations and that's what
happened you remember with Boris Johnson
Sajid Javid went Rishi soon out went and
that was the Tipping Point and the herd
moved and then he was gone by when's
what Thursday morning that week okay so
the question I've got is James cleverley
has just been contradicted hours later
by the Prime Minister Jeremy Hunt has
just been contradicted by the Prime
Minister did she get an agreement or is
she just trying to overrule her
Chancellor and if she is what's the
backlash going to be I don't know the
answers it's just happened but my
analysis would be that that could be a
real hot potato for her let's see what
I'm very interested to see how Jeremy
Hunt reacts to that fascinating times
Well ahead of prime minister's questions
we spoke to a panel of Voters in
Bridgewater in some of that conservative
voters in the conservative heartlands a
true blue constituency that's voted
conservative for decades well let's
return there now on our west of England
correspondent Dan Whitehead Dan what
kind of response has there been
yeah we had our panel watching in our
SAT truck pmqs throughout that half an
hour let's get that instant reaction we
are joined back by the panel uh now
Evelyn Wilson you are a mobile
hairdresser you've just been watching uh
Lee's trust she says she is a fighter
not a quitter are you convinced no no
not truster one bit
um she's just going around in a circle
and she's just always got an answer for
everything
she she was trying to reassure uh the
commons a party the voters that she's
still in control
how did you feel that went no I don't
think she's still in control
I don't feel that she is really you
didn't get any of the answers that you
wanted to reassure you them no
no okay well let's let's chat with um
with Alan Jeffrey a retired secretary
school teacher and a pensioner Alan um
we heard there a commitment there on the
triple lock pension um committed to that
Manifesto uh commitment
um does that come as welcome news for
you and how are you feeling about her
performance
I I think it is it is very useful for
those pensioners who really do need it
but there are an awful lot of pensioners
who don't necessarily need that the real
people who really need the support are
the working-class people who aren't
pensioners don't have a pension and
they're having Rising prices of their
Lodge of their rents the food costs
their traveling costs and trying to
support their families watching her how
did you feel that performance went
it was very robotic and she keeps on
repeating the same old statements which
are just words
uh there's no real actions that she can
really do from from those words looking
at the front bench there do you feel
it's a unified cabinet a Unified
Government
certainly not
uh there is all sorts of problems all
through her government uh it's
completely divided to our party it's
time that we just got rid of them after
their 12 years of mismanagement of the
economy mismanagement of our Public
Services it's time we had a fresh start
and an election really should be on the
way to get rid of the mismanagement of
this this carried on this democracy you
want an election Alan let's bring in a
third member who watched the whole of
pmqs with us our previous guest had to
leave but we were joined Now by
Claudette Tinsley you're in your 30s
you're on a graphic design business or
that you were with us watching pmqs your
initial reaction after a turbulent few
weeks on how the Prime Minister dealt
with that
um I think she has pretty flimsy
promises to offer they seem to be
u-turning and if you turn around now if
you're going in circles
um I think that um whatever she says now
can change next week it's it's changed
every couple of days so it's a trust
issue for you uh yes but also their
record they've been in power for 12
years and they've not they've been given
enough chances they say oh give her a
chance I'll give this person a chance
but even if they replaced her that
they've been given multiple chances
repeatedly and they they don't finish
their terms they just swap out the next
leader and hope for a fresh start but
what could you hope that the current
prime minister does
in the next two years before an election
or sooner to convince you that they're
in control
I don't think that they can do anything
that would make me believe them because
they've said so many things and have had
to U-turn in is an incredible amount of
u-turns they don't
keep their promises and even the ones
that they keep they don't seem to be
popular at all really and then they have
to make decisions that
by popular demand against their original
promises you know that such as the help
with the energy that she wasn't leading
on that when she was going for her
leadership and then as soon as she got
in she had to say oh yes we'll help with
energy but it's reluctantly done so I
don't believe whatever she says Evelyn
let's just come back to you quickly um
you know let's trust talked about there
that the reiteration on the promise to
to have that energy price cap yeah you
know everyone's seeing their bills going
up and someone who runs a mobile
business and also a home with family
members yeah
did enough for you to say let's just
give the government another chance
um no I don't think so no
um you know with the electric people are
cutting back they're economizing and
they're you know they're keeping their
electric off as long as they can
um and that's something you're having
too yeah that's that's what I'm doing
because I don't want to pay that it's
like a principle as well why should we
have to pay those extortionate prices in
the first place so
you know keep it off as long as you can
if it means putting blankets over you
and jumpers on then do that
you were a Boris backer previous uh
yeah it's been lots of talk about that
isn't there any
what do you want to happen next because
a lot of people say we can't go through
another leadership well I think they
should um do another vote a vote for the
for the public another you know because
of that you know an election yeah and
yeah if they can another election I know
they can only do that every four years
isn't it well that's changed but would
you like a general election is that what
you want now yeah another general
election let the public
get their votes in and decide
is that the only answer in your opinion
I know that's something you've supported
but is it sounds like that not enough
has been done in your opinion
well it's disastrous government over the
last 12 years sort of thing has got us
into the situation it's time to have a
real refreshment of policies and the way
we're really going to try and support
the working people of this country the
people who keep the country going not
the privatized companies that send all
the profits from this company from this
country abroad
and just called it just just lastly
interested to know as a young person
what the big challenges are here in a
rural constituency uh are
what what is your top priority for the
government and Liz trust in in the time
that they've got I think supporting
workers rather than saying that they're
she says she was supporting the Strivers
um but that was in relation to trade
unions and claiming it's basically
saying that trade Union people aren't
hard workers um I'm obviously not a
trade Union person myself but I support
people who are hard workers and our
young families they can't afford all the
rising costs of food and electricity and
everything and I feel like that they
seem to try and demonize a certain set
of workers because they don't suit their
uh their needs but um I think that there
needs to be more support for workers
personally your biggest concern as a
young person what's top of your list
energy is still a top part it's it's
costs of living you know that affect a
lot of people that's the day-to-day cost
for most people it's not
um something you can escape from so I
think energy still is a big thing so
then they're now cutting that help to
six months so what happens next year you
know these promises only last a certain
amount of time that they make
um and so it's a bit it's a bit unsure
whether they'll keep supporting people
and young families but also older
Generations you know with the pension
it's important to support those that are
struggling and they just seem to keep
giving bonuses to Bankers they don't
need all these extra bonuses what we
need is more infrastructure support I
think more investment in the railways
more investment in things that used to
be
nationalized and now are privatized and
all these parts are Key Parts people
need to get a bus to get to work people
need a train to get to work and if they
can't afford it and they can't afford to
live in the area you'll end up with
people who can't afford to travel to
work all those issues uh significant in
a rural local location like this very
quickly yes or no give Liz truss another
chance no
give let's try another chance certainly
not no not at all no well they're pretty
uh pretty unanimous uh poll there from a
strong conservative majority majority of
25 000 here in Bridgewater and the panel
that we've been speaking to I think that
too many promises have been broken too
many uh u-turns and the opinion of these
three people here from businesses to
pensioners to young people starting
businesses of their own is it it's gone
too far and there have been too many uh
promises broken and an election seems to
be at the call from this conservative
stronghold
Dan thanks very much for that
well let's just take you back to prime
minister's questions it was a crucial
pmqs for Liz truss and we are here
analyzing her performance let's remind
ourselves of some of the key exchanges
from The Commons a short time ago
I have been very clear that
um
that I am sorry
and that I have made mistakes but the
right thing to do in those circumstances
is to make changes which I've made and
to get on with the job and deliver for
the British people a book is being
written about the prime minister's time
in office
apparently it's going to be out by
Christmas is that the release date or
the title
how can she be held to account when
she's not in charge
[Applause]
so now I I had to take the decision
because of the economic situation to
adjust our policies
somebody who's prepared to front up I'm
prepared to take the tough decisions
unlike The Honorable gentleman who
hasn't done anything on businesses he's
done nothing to say or protect people
after one year he's got no plan Mr
Speaker last week the Prime Minister
stood there and promised absolutely no
spending reductions they all cheered
this week the chancellor announced a new
wave of cuts what's the point of a prime
minister whose promises don't even last
a week
and a built on fantasy economics and it
ended in disaster the country's got
nothing to show for it except the
destruction of the economy and the
implosion of the Tory party I've got the
list here 45p tax cut gone corporation
tax cut gone 20p tax cut gone two-year
energy freeze gone tax-free shopping
gone economic credibility gone
and her supposed best friend the formula
Chancellor he's gone as well they're all
gone so why is she still here
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I am a fighter and not a
quetter
well we heard from the conservative mp
uh John Stevenson MP for Carlisle uh
just before the Prime Minister stood up
and he's very kindly come back to give
us his verdict on how she did
um in terms of her performance how do
you think she did well it's definitely
demonstrates her resilience and I think
it was a very robust performance by the
Prime Minister indeed I'd probably say
it's been her best pmqs outing that
she's had although only three so
demonstrated her resilience her
willingness to continue in the job and I
also think she had The Bravery to
apologize for what she'd done in terms
of the original policy decisions and now
she is moving on which I fully support
we've got to move on she's got the new
Chancellor in place he's bringing
forward the policies that will bring
stability to the market and more
importantly he will set out our vision
for the future on the 31st of October
well you mentioned a chance Liberty
appeared to contradict something that he
had said earlier in the week he had said
that he wasn't going to make any
decisions on spending cuts until the end
of the month and then she then announced
that the triple lock and pensions would
remain
do you sense that there's something
going on there that there's a Divergence
between the two of them I don't know the
conversations that go on between the
prime minister and her Chancellor but I
do know that was a Manifesto commitment
and I think the back benches would
certainly want to see that be retained
as a policy so I think what the Prime
Minister was saying was in fact the
reality of the situation which is that
there will be that uplift in pensions
and it's something that I would
certainly be supporting and I'm sure my
colleagues in the back benches would
certainly be supporting we're going to
come to a political letter to Beth Ruby
in a second but first of all just need
to bring the latest pictures we have of
the Russian President Vladimir Putin
he's addressing his Security Council in
Moscow let's listen in
and
we guarantee that this will be done with
a guaranteed degree of reliability
very recently there has been a lot of
disaffection uh with the uh order
raining in the armed forces but I have
today issued a decree which uh rectifies
that
and uh a big allocation from the budget
for humanitarian assistance and also for
training of personnel
foreign
and this of course includes volunteers
and for
the mobilization effort
colleagues
we are working
on improving a large scale Security
operation
to defend our people
and those